I'm about to help a complete stranger
build a $7 million per year business.
I'm going to give him a step-by-step
road map on exactly what he needs to do.
And 90 days later, we're going to check
in with him to see what actually
happened. And for all the business
owners watching, I've scaled 10
businesses past 10 million, three past
100 million, and I've realized an
important lesson, which is that
businesses behave in patterns at all
levels. And so, you can take any of the
principles and tactics and apply them to
your specific business and industry. At
its current size, there are far more
similarities than there are differences.
And so, with that being said, let's go
meet Caleb. Ready to rock?
>> I'm ready to rock and roll, brother.
>> All right. Tell me about the business.
>> So, first off, my name is Caleb with a
K. I own Keys Roofing Company,
>> also with a K.
>> Yeah. All right. Alex with an A. Nice to
meet you.
>> So, we are a premium and luxury roofing,
gutter, and downspout contractor in St.
Louis, Missouri.
>> Hey, what's going on, folks? This is
Caleb with [music] the K, the Kingdom
Building Castle Contractor.
>> So, we've been in business for 2 months.
The current revenue, um, we're a little
bit shy of 41,000. Profit is 24,248, so
I'm at about 59%.
>> So, you're doing only 20K a monthish
right now. All right. Correct. The goal
within the next 3 years is going to be 7
to 10 million.
>> Okay. Love that. So, how you get
customers?
>> So, the way that we get customers, um,
two primary acquisition channels
currently is door-knocking. So, I do a
ton of canvasing and then also
referrals, whether that's doing a great
job for the person that I currently meet
or people within my internal network.
>> So, walk me through the money stuff.
>> Yeah. Um, so with the money stuff, I
have two streams of revenue with the
full replacements. My average ticket
year after year is about 18 to 25,000.
>> The greatest thing about being the
solution for the smaller problems is
these jobs, Alex, they typically chunk
up to those jobs. So if I'm coming
through and I replace one down spout for
somebody, run a gutters, what have you,
nobody will else will even show up to
even attack that job, which then
qualifies me to get the next job and all
their future jobs.
>> How many doors do you need to knock to
get a sale?
>> Oh man, I have a high um close rate on
that. So if I knock 20 doors,
>> I'm getting a sale.
>> Yeah.
>> Like it's like that.
>> Yeah. No, it's like that.
>> It's like that.
>> Like that. [laughter]
>> All right. Um
what's stopping you right now?
>> So what's currently stopping me is um
having more salespeople because if I
have two more salespeople, one project
manager, I'm 100% confident 7 to 10
million is very doable.
>> Okay. Um why is this important to you?
I would say this is important to me
because um I have two kids at home. So
Wayan is three. My son August is 10
months old.
>> Oh, congrats.
>> Oftentimes we look to our parents, oh
like you know how to be successful and
they'll give us all these things. And
for me as dad,
>> I need to show my kids what winning
looks like.
>> So that's first and foremost. But also
secondly is I believe the roofing
experience is primarily across the board
terrible for both customers and roofing
salespeople alike. So, the ability to
solve this problem gives salespeople a
great ecosystem to come and sell and
actually be paid for what they do. Yeah.
And then it allows me to have satisfied
customers in the St. Louis area with the
unmatched offer that I do.
>> Um, all right. Hop on to the side and
then we'll uh we'll dive into it.
>> Awesome. [music]
>> Okay. So, um, the big thing that you
right now have to deal with is like
there's one of you and there you don't
have that many like it's a small
business, right? Right? And I'm not
saying that as a slide. I'm saying just
factually, right? Um and so you're going
to be resourcing strength both time and
money. And so I want to focus all
efforts on the highest return stuff that
you can do right now. Um what's very
good about your business right now,
honestly, is you because at any given
point, you can knock 20 doors and you
get a deal.
>> Yep.
>> Right. And so that reliability of being
able to just basically go get money um
is something that a lot of entrepreneurs
don't know how to do. And that gives you
a lot of what I'll call like cats have
nine lives. like entrepreneurs uh need
as many lives as they can and knowing
how to go get money is one of the ways
to do that. So, I think it's super good.
Um there's a couple key decisions that I
wanted to like walk through because one
of the considerations I had was like,
okay, was there a world where we could
get repair average tickets up more
meaningfully? Yeah.
>> And so, say 7K is gross profit on the
replacements. Sure. Does that sound
fair?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, if we have 7K replacements,
right?
Um, what is the gross profit on a
repair? Oh,
>> I'm at like 64%.
>> And that average ticket is 1,500.
>> Yep.
>> So, $1,100 um gross profit on repairs.
So, I'll tell you where I was originally
thinking was basically, is there a world
where, let's say we get this gross
profit up to $2,000. Is there a world
where you think you could sell three
times as many repairs as you could
replacements?
>> 100,000%.
>> Right? So, this is what got more
interesting to me was like I love when
there it's like when when there's
something that's been cast aside by
other people, right? Like no one wants
to do this particular thing, but then
you orient a business in such a way that
you can actually make really good gross
profits on it. Part of me was running
out the idea of like what if we just did
repairs and you did an absolute like you
just became you systemized the living
out of it, right? So, what is the
aggregate amount of all repairs? What
would that ticket look like? So, if you
did everything minus replacement,
>> these should really be selling for like
2500 to 5K. The reason that this is
interesting to me is that like if we can
get this thing to two, three, you know,
4K.
>> Sure.
>> This becomes an incredibly interesting
business.
>> Yeah.
>> Just from the sheer volume that you
could do and the reliability of revenue
cuz the obvious one is cool. We do
repairs and then we try and upsell the
upsell the roofs. Like that's fine. Um
but I just like that you have this angle
a lot. Hey, it's Alex from the future. I
just thought it might be really
interesting to see what actually happens
to Caleb when he implements this stuff.
And so we're going to show you how much
his revenue increased by at the end. How
has the business changed since switching
from uh chasing full roof replacements
to repair volume? And it's interesting
because I was doing like 15 to 20
services per month, but with the new
model, I do about 60 to 80 per month
right now. And so it's more than
quadrupled in terms of uh services sold,
built, and collected on. So I would say
that it's it's been working. Our roof
repair techs, they do about 3 to five
jobs per day. Um, I have one currently.
Once the second one comes on, I mean,
we're doubling up even on that.
>> Well, I would say that was pretty good.
That uh that was a good one of those one
of those good ideas out of nothing to
add. Let's just run this out and like
run out a version of the future. Okay.
So, let's just say that we try and get
really really sexy with our repair sales
motion.
>> Sure.
>> All right. So, all the repairs we try
and get our foot in the door quite
literally, right? Mhm.
>> We get our repairs and then they go to
um have their onboarding call with
Amanda. Right. Prior to the onboarding
call, I would love to have them watch a
VSSL that talks about the other the
benefits of what you guys do. It's a
long-term investment. Blah blah blah
blah. Right. Um, and then Amanda then
tries to close them on a menu close of,
okay, uh, you got this thing, but you
probably don't need this. You probably
don't need this, but what you really
going to probably want to take care of
is this and this, which, you know, my my
partner didn't have enough time to to
talk about, but given what we now know
about it because we did a little bit
more work than just talking to you. Um,
we're all going to be there. We're going
to have the dumpsters out. We're already
going to have the tarps open. It's like
you might like the the hood's going to
get popped, right? So, you might as well
just have us fix everything while we're
here. Getting the first sale is the hard
part. Getting the approximate sale is
significantly easier.
>> Way easier. Right.
>> Can I ask you a question about this? So,
with the VSSL, so I have a a high
quality YouTube channel. Is a VSSL kind
of the same as a YouTube or is that
different?
>> It's it's has a more specific purpose.
As you scale the sales team, you might
want this video to be more targeted in
terms of like more s.
>> Okay.
>> Right. And so the the VSSL structure
looks more like this, which is you have
your intro
and then you're going to have your
promise of like, hey, in this video I'm
going to explain X, Y, and Z, which is
the promise that they want. you're gonna
have an amazing roof and blah blah blah
and it's gonna help you avoid
>> this pain that you probably dealt with
in the past x y and z. Um, and so you
might not believe me because you just
met me and so let me just give you some
proof of Angie and Daniel and so and so
that are all around this area have
houses as big or bigger than yours so
you can feel like I work with people of
your caliber.
>> Um, and so in this video I'll show you
the plan of how we actually do that. And
so then we have old way new way
>> which is the way that the current
industry looks is this. and our special
K right uh process is X Y and Z and
that's why it's very different than the
you know the old way of doing things and
then we say okay now clients typically
have a couple questions around this
stuff and so we have objection number
one through whatever n uh objections
that they have and with each of those
you just break the beliefs you're like
uh they think this here's why that's
wrong or they didn't know this this is
what's right and here's proof
and so you know Angela a similar
question. She owns whatever house down
the street and um she thought this it
actually works like this instead. Um and
so here's proof, right? So each one of
those is basically that's just a belief
breaking mechanism over and over again.
And so that way your sales guy when he
comes back after, you know, walking the
house and this is like a 7-minute video,
whatever.
>> Um you be like, "Oh, video give you a
little bit more context." It completely
edifies them, edifies the company, gives
a shitload of social proof and stats.
Yep. And so like I would also bring in
something like uh you know uh houses
that have some sort of roofing plan um
resell at a higher value. Like I would
>> put those pieces into it. So it's like
you're actually not really paying for
this. Uh you're going to pay for it
either way. It's just you get to enjoy
the house without all the issues the
whole time, but it ends up reflecting
your home value.
>> I see.
>> So you might as well just like the worst
thing you can do is fix all these things
the day that you sell the house and you
could have just had a nice roof this
whole time and sold it for the same
value, but instead you're just fixing
your house for the next guy.
>> Makes sense. Okay. That's how I would
sell it. Sure.
>> Right. Um, and so this is before you
actually close, but then you before you
talk to Amanda,
>> right?
>> They should still watch another one. So
they watch one when you're on camp like
on property
>> and then cuz [clears throat] this is
about the first sale.
>> Understood.
>> The VSSL that they're going to talk to
you from Amanda. So this is VSSLs in
general. But the VSSL that they're going
to see when they talk to Amanda is about
the other stuff.
>> Got it.
>> So it's just it's just framing the
conversation. So this is probably more a
little bit more about us and working
with us in general. This is going to be
more about other things that people
don't know about like their roots.
>> Mhm.
>> So it's you get the difference.
>> I'm thinking about that.
>> Got it. Yep.
>> Now I think that in terms of scale, you
should go all in door to door.
>> Okay.
>> It's what you're good at.
>> Like I don't think we need to be cute
about this.
>> Sure.
>> Um and just get really violent with it.
>> Nice. I'm down for that.
>> Yeah. I just It's like I have full focus
on this. If you just every 20 doors and
maybe it's every 40 for your guys or
every 50 for them, whatever.
like
it's like I want to go make money. It's
like great. So, you know, your
commissions I don't know what would a
commission on this be.
>> So, we do 10% on repairs.
>> So, let's say the average uh repair we
can get that to like 4K revenue,
>> right? So, 4K revenue, they're going to
get 400 bucks.
>> Yep.
>> Right. Divided by uh 50 doors. So, it's
like, want to go make 10 bucks? Knock
that door. Want to make another 10
bucks? Knock that door. Want to make
another 10 bucks? Knock that door. It's
just like it just makes it really
straightforward for them. So, it's like
how much money do you want to make? Just
knock that many doors.
>> That's the piece,
>> right? Yep. Um, and I think you building
out this DDD army is like the clear
straight shot.
>> When I came back from scale or fail, my
biggest thing was like, how do I go all
in on door knockocking and just
basically do more of what's working and
just sell more jobs, get more services
completed. Uh, that dedication has
resulted in us doing literally more than
four times the sales velocity that we
were doing. And quite honestly, I feel
that I'm a few deletions in terms of my
own like habits that I got to kick or
like delegations I got to put out there
of selling 20 to 40 more services per
month.
>> Awesome. I mean, at the end of the day,
it always comes down to the team. So,
kudos that he was being a good leader
and pushing credit down because that's
what you got to do.
>> Okay. So, what are you doing on the back
end when you deliver the house?
>> So, like full job's finished is what
you're saying.
>> Mhm.
>> So, we have like a cleanup process, too.
So, like I make sure that the house is
better looking than how we left it.
>> And then the first thing that we're
going to do is ask them for a Google
review. I also come from a background of
like financial advising and mortgage.
So, I want to make sure LTV is high. And
the way that you do that is you actually
stay in good contact with your clients.
I get a lot of business just by I call
these people every six months to a year.
>> I have detailed notes. Hey, how's your
kids doing?
>> Let me give you a cool little thing.
>> What you got?
>> Okay. [laughter]
So you're going to do your like you're
going to get your review and you're
going to get your reel. So what I do is
give an incentive.
>> So I want to say, hey, so what most
people do is they sign up for our, you
know, diamond
roofing call whatever you want. VIP.
>> Mhm.
>> And it's $15 to $20 a month.
>> Just paid annually.
>> So it's 180 to 240. Depends on the
market, right? You can go a little
higher if you want to.
And uh we put uh $2 for every $1 that
you put on this into future repairs.
Typically people need to get their roof
checked once a year. Um and so we'll
come out
>> for that to check on everything, make
sure it's up to date, and we'll take it
out of the repair that we have to do.
>> Okay. Okay. So you're you're more
talking about like a the maintenance
program, like something like that. Okay.
Yeah, I like that.
>> Yeah. And then if you want to, and this
is like where we can we can get a little
bit niftier. It's like you can make this
$500 a year.
>> Um, but if you just leave us a review,
we'll knock it down to 200.
>> Okay.
>> And now we have a little a little
carrot. Yeah.
>> For them. But at the end of the day, you
don't we just we don't even care about
the money. We care about the fact that
we're going to have appointment see that
we're going to go out to see the person.
Yeah.
>> And then
>> Yeah.
>> sell more stuff.
>> Let's do that.
>> Yeah.
>> Good idea, dude.
>> Yeah. I actually do this for a living.
Um,
>> so we have launched it and I've put a
few offers out there on it. I'll be the
first to tell you that I need to find a
better way like in my sales motion on
how to get that through and an offer
that really makes sense. Uh, there's
been some commercial maintenance that
we've done that we've done a fantastic
job on, but in terms of like throwing
that on residential, I'm still finding
my way.
>> I'll have to ask that. I'll have to ask
Cale about that when I see him. Um to
figure out where where he's putting it
because it's probably a timing thing. Um
and I'll have to see how he's actually
like scripting the words around it. Um
because if you can tack that on the end,
it takes the business from being onetime
business to recurring business, which is
obviously significantly more valuable
and dramatically increases LTV. So, it's
one of those like it's kind of it's
sometimes just tweaking a couple things.
Um and then all of a sudden it's like
boom, it clicks and then you're getting
80% or buying it. So,
because you're starting out, the It's
funny because the the bigger the
business, the more tailored the um
advice has to be because there's just
more moving pieces and considerations.
>> The earlier like at at the hypothetical
stream at the beginning, the first step
of starting a business is always the
same, which is that you will need to
start an LLC of some kind so that you
can accept money.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right. So, it's like if every if you're
at zero, the steps are identical. And if
you're at a zillion, the steps are
entirely unique. You're a few steps from
zero, eight weeks. Right. Yeah.
>> Um, and so, uh, the process here is
really, really straightforward. We need
to add tweak this front end VSSL, add a
backend VSSL. Amanda needs to follow a
script in terms of like, um, I like the
menu close. So, the menu the the the the
menu the menu process works like this.
Step one is that Amanda's going to
unsell
what they don't need.
>> Mhm.
>> So, she gains trust.
>> She's like, "Hey, looks like you're this
is fine. Looks like this is it. You
probably have a couple years on this.
Don't worry about that. Don't worry
about that." And then they're like, "Oh,
wow. She's not going to try and upsell
me a bunch of shit." You're like,
"Yeah."
The second thing um is we're going to
we're going to prescribe what we do
think they need. So, you don't need
this. You don't need this. You don't
need this. You don't need this. But what
I am saying is you're probably going to
need this and this and this.
>> Mhm.
>> Now,
would you prefer A or B?
>> Gotcha.
>> Would you rather have a male or female
person doing the install? Would you
rather start on Monday or Tuesday? Would
you rather like
>> Yeah,
>> it doesn't matter. Like would you rather
the neon nails or the the white nails?
>> Coffee or water?
>> It's a fake. Yeah, it's a fake choice,
but it just makes the clothes a lot
easier.
>> Mhm.
>> And then four, [panting]
>> card on file.
>> Mhm.
>> Great. You just put that on the card
that we already the payment method we
have on file. Awesome. That's the
script.
>> Yeah.
>> So, welcome. We're excited to really
have you. I looked at some of the
images. Um, it looks great. Look, you
know, your gutters look great. The blah
blah blah looks great. You know,
beautiful home that you got here. So, I
don't think you're going to need this
and this and this. You are going to
probably need to take care of this. And
so, would you rather this or this?
Great. You want to take care of that
with a card file? I mean, we already
have the hood popped up. That work for
you. Great.
>> Nice. Yeah.
>> Super smooth.
>> Yes. And we're good about this, too. So,
we could definitely do that.
>> Buttery.
>> Nice.
>> And so, that's a script for Amanda to
follow.
>> Cold. Love to see it.
>> How is the menu upsell going in terms of
like prescribing people a solution? Uh,
taking something off the table. This has
been one of the most the most effective
strategies that I've injected into my
business because I get to give my raw
authentic opinion to people and it
automatically builds that trust because
not every product is for every person.
So I have to look at the variety of
solutions that I have and say this one
is made specifically for you Janet for
this reason. Um people like that
>> the menu epsile absolutely slays. It is
my favorite of the If you had to ask me
what is my favorite chapter in the money
models book, it is the menu upsell. It's
in the upsell section. If you have any
kind of transactional sale that's like
you're not doing a super complex thing,
but it's like you can do it in one
conversation. It absolutely slays. Like
it is it is I have I spent so long
honing that process. If you have the
opportunity to use it, it's in the book.
My book's online for free. If you want
the hard copy, you can grab it. But like
it crushes. We This is the process
because all we're doing is we're going
to increase average ticket with this via
menu uh sale process. The two VSLs, one
for you and then one for her.
>> We're gonna get more reoccurring
business on the back end with our little
membership that we're going to credit
towards any repairs.
>> Mhm.
>> You're going to need to do it either
way. So, you might as well just not even
feel it.
>> Sure.
>> And then we shove scale door to door.
>> Got it. I had a speed incentive in play,
too.
>> It's all margin.
>> Yeah. Oh, for sure. So, the way I think
about like the reason that I'm such a
big proponent of speed, right, is let's
say that you've got
So, you got house A, B, C. We'll put a
little put some roofs on for for keys,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, we've got house ABC. If like we have
to do this amount of work and this
amount of work is going to take the same
amount of resources, but if C wants to
pay us an extra th,000 and A is still
very much within the window of like an
acceptable time period to get the repair
done.
>> Mhm.
>> We might as well just make it C B A or
CA B, whatever.
>> But literally just reshifting the order
of the work by allowing people to spend
more to go first
>> just makes more money.
>> Correct.
>> And so when you do the end of your
repair thing, it's like, hey, you know,
we always try to be really fast, but for
a lot of our clients, you know, time is
money. um we have a 20% um priority
>> sure
>> boost. So if you want us to get this
done um for sure by the end of the week
and if we don't we don't even charge it.
Uh we basically put you at the front of
the line and then you don't have to
worry about it.
>> Okay, I'm with that. Yeah, that's good.
Cuz if I mix that, I have like a
prepayment incentive.
>> So yeah, and I mean speed's all margin
and in this business margin matters a
lot.
>> Ton.
>> So I would say you can tack that on to
the initial here.
>> Yeah. But if we can get the average
ticket up to that 2, three, 4K because
of this motion.
>> And then you add your speed piece in,
all of a sudden you guys can start doing
two, three, four repairs a day. It's
like doing a full
>> roof replacement a day.
>> That's what I'm saying. Like that's why
I love the repairs because I'm not
competing with anybody on these guys
think they're too good for it.
>> Yeah. I just like it. I love I if I can
I love high volume businesses
>> just because there's more stability. the
the reps get way more like the sales
reps get way more reps um in because the
sales cycle is much shorter. There's way
less um administrative uh headache with
the insurance and the payment that's
delayed. There's there's basically no
cash flow constraints with the business
and you can just
>> and then you just add more of these and
that literally becomes the machine.
>> So I actually have not only rolled that
out but had some of my first takers as
of recently um a commercial client that
had an emergency on their job. Uh
basically threw him a quote out there.
was like, "Hey, we could either do this
next week or I can get to it tomorrow
for x amount more um extra 300 bucks of
like straight margin." Uh they took it,
got the job completely done, they were
super satisfied, and not only was it
like effective, but they wanted to buy
the next job right after it. So, speed
works, baby. If you're ever not sure how
to add margin to a business, especially
if you're supply constraint, meaning you
have more people who want your stuff
than you have the ability to do, add
speed incentives for people to just move
to the front of the line. You do the
same amount of work and you just make
more money. There's a lot of things that
are very exciting right now and it's
also new and whatever.
>> Sure.
>> But like we need to knock more doors
>> and we sell more repairs.
>> Gotcha.
>> How's that sit?
>> That sits really well with me. I mean I
came here for some clear direction and I
feel I have actionable steps on what
needs to have happen. So it's just a
matter of debriefing it with the team
and putting systems in play.
>> Simple.
>> Barry.
>> Cool. Appreciate you.
>> Nice to meet you, bro. I think we have a
little scaling road map. What's that
count right now?
>> Uh four, five once Alejandro, my sales
guy joins.
>> Alejandro.
>> Where we at? So that's going to be 1 to
four to 5 to 9. You're right in this
little little transition here.
>> Mhm.
>> So what we were talking about today was
basically specializing our product.
>> Okay.
>> Right. Um from a marketing perspective,
uh the free stuff, you've like you're
already on your way with this in terms
of making the content. Mhm.
>> Uh so you're you're you're on the right
direction with that.
>> Sure.
>> Uh from a sales perspective, you're
going to probably have to track this
maybe a little bit more than you are
right now cuz right now you're the it's
you.
>> Mhm.
>> Um but as the team scales up, this is
going to probably be the next piece that
you're going to want to have to install.
>> Um and then you do, it sounds like you
have better tracking on the back end
because you have some experience there.
>> Um but in order to get to this next
level over here, that's what we have to
basically check those boxes off. And you
have about half of them. So I think you
are ready to like gas this. So um with
this I want you to think about sales
people as your new customers or your new
avatar.
>> Yeah.
>> And some of the marketing that you're
going to do is to go get these guys so
that all of a sudden you can have four
guys on your team or five guys on your
team and you can probably easily manage
that on your own.
>> Mhm.
>> And then that's what's going to allow
you to unlock this. The thing and that's
again with with volume comes
reliability. And with reliability you
can get you can you can decrease costs
because you can forecast. And
>> so fundamentally what you're what you're
discussing is like I can start
forecasting out that if I know I'm going
to hit this volume then I can cut my
cost basis in half or by 2/3. It's like
okay yeah and that's how business is
done.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. In the beginning it's always
super rocky because everything's really
volatile and it's feast or famine.
>> That's why I like the reliability of
this in the beginning. So we get cash
flow and there's a heartbeat in the
business. Uh and then everyone just kind
of like water starts flowing through the
pipes. Straightforward though.
>> Yeah.
>> Like it.
>> Well I want every entrepreneur to win.
And so I think what's more important or
more interesting is what actually
happened when he executed all the stuff
um that I outlined for him over the next
90 days. And so that's what we're going
to show you. Give me the update. So what
was what was revenue 3 months ago again?
>> So it was a little under 32,000
>> and then um I guess it's been 90 days
since then is so uh what is it now?
>> So right now I am at 250,000. So like
yeah it's like 247.
>> Hell yeah.
>> But it's been rolling, bro. Like when I
came on I was sub 20 reviews. So I'm at
62 fivestar reviews, 85 services built,
sold, and collected on whereas I was at
32 over there.
>> Hired the repair tech.
>> It's been a lot of stuff, dude. Like
I've never tried this hard in my entire
freaking life. And I absolutely love
this.
>> Which things did you do that uh made the
biggest impact?
>> So I went all in on door todoor first
off and I had to figure out how to
structure that.
>> Alex, who genuinely helped me the most,
I would say. So, I actually went and got
an ERP system. So, it's like a custom
CRM that is built for us that is
allowing me to like run the jobs the way
that I want.
>> So, now that I have the repair tech, um
I am doing three to five services every
single day.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. My guy um it's it's been wild too
cuz he actually ended up having meniscus
surgery yesterday.
>> Ah,
>> and his brother filled in his role. So
when they both come on at the same time,
I'm going to take that 3 to five
services a day and it's really going to
look like six to eight and I am just
going to win by just absolute violence.
I have decided.
>> I mean that is the uh that is the I
think the the first thing we said was go
all in on door to door as primary growth
engine.
>> Yes, the VSSL. So I'm shooting the VSSL
come next week. Your prescription idea
has been monumental to in terms of I'm
going to talk to people about hey let's
say all the gutter guards. Yeah,
>> there's one option that no, you don't
want this because of XYZ and then I'm
prescribing what they need. So that
consultative aspect to selling is
increasing trust a lot and then people
are just taking every recommendation.
>> The menu upsell, baby.
>> Yeah. So,
>> so tweaked the tweaked the motion, went
all in on door todoor, tweaked the tech
so you could sell more. Um, and yeah,
and you're getting in only the the big
dogs in terms of producers, right?
>> Oh, yeah. It sounds like a pretty
productive 90 days.
>> I've had a monomomaniacal focus on most
everything he's put into that list and
I've ROIed on every single move. Asking
myself too is like, you know, how can I
do more? Like, I've never tried this
hard in my entire life. And you know
that the advice is good when all you
really feel that you need is like, hey,
I just need 90 more days. Like that's
I'm satisfied.
>> Oh god, he's satisfied. That's good.
[laughter]
Um, yeah, it's nice when stuff works
without I mean, what's interesting is
like, think about how if you play a
video game and you've played the game
before, how fast you move through the
levels until you get to a level that you
haven't played [clears throat] before.
Like, that is the advantage of having
some insight from ahead looking back
saying, "Hey, man, just go here, go
here." And what you don't see is like,
well, I stayed stuck here for 3 months
because I didn't know what to do. So,
it's like when you have the right
directions, you can just the only uh
hold back is just pure execution, just
absolute violence. and he said he's got
my monomaniacal focus and what he's
doing and it's showing
>> everything that you told me has worked.
I will say that.
>> Well, I love to hear it and congrats on
going from 30K to 240K [laughter]
uh in 90 days. It's all you, dude.
That's all you. I'm glad we could just
be one small one small step in there.
>> Yeah. All of
>> Appreciate you, brother. All right. And
so that was this episode of Scale or
Fail. Stay tuned for the next one as
they all compete for $100,000 in a year
of working on scaling.